yeah I had a girl who dancer used to
dance she used to be a stripper and we
did it and she said that she ended up
dating I said he ever date a client she
goes I did once and I said that's a lie
did a lot but let's just say you dance
and I said I didn't what succulence a
the guy walked in and she goes oh he
wasn't she wasn't attracted to him he's
older he's like my age 50 something with
you know yeah and yeah it's kind of like
I've kind of a thick kind of dude and he
said don't care about coming back he
came back like three times and he just
liked her and finally he said so I want
to I want to spend more time with you
and I don't want to do it here she goes
oh I don't do that and he goes yeah I
know he said but what's your rent and
she goes hey before you go on yes guys
named Brian Cal his name is Brian yeah
but it wasn't me so she said that he
ended up not only did he pay her he goes
he goes she was hitting on guys I'll
tell you what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
give you $15,000 a month well I have a
hefty price hey I'm hiding a shade a
little not me you guys I'll give you a
$15,000 a month and you just sucked me
on your round she said she goes I
couldn't say no it was so much good but
she took her like she's your sister and
her brother on a vacation summer and she
goes and I beak and then I just practice
but it's true she was like he was like
did they get married it was undeniable
do you made Deb she SAT me to so
undeniable now she foolish yeah those
gray you're not very romantic girl of
scorpions that's a hot though 15 grand a
month at start lower back to the gym I
was single and there was some smoke
showing a [ __ ] strip club and I was
like dude I will up I'd pay five grand a
month just to whatever yeah hell yeah he
had money and she was like she's just
right deal okay you know who does that
is James Harden
because he doesn't want to get me to to
have fake rape accusations so he was
paying this I think it was show us
something just this biker with a oh I
see her you'd pay her Jenna Shay I think
you'd pay her a monthly fee okay I'm I
endorsed it
people like dude so she's a professional
he's at yeah I don't give a [ __ ] I
endorsed that a hundred percent that's
probably I approve let me see more
pictures please
I'm gonna get my hand on my pants this
is gonna be weird yeah you would pay her
and just like he didn't have to worry
about anything she's not getting
pregnant nothing she's gonna call
whenever he wanted yeah I have a look at
her look at her
yeah yeah she's thick though huh
she dick he's good yeah for sure she's
done she's done the rounds probably look
at the hips what's that say an escort
tells one NBA wife her man oh she's
talking [ __ ] to uh Dan she heard she is
bodied up a little bit of tummy on it I
don't mind that at all no she's just
cursed snog got hurt a little Georgia
Peach huh
she will suck you dry B you don't know
dude you don't know if that's what she's
about you yes on her now listen I'm sure
I have a hunch
I'm not an expert yeah she's in the
black guys well I'll tell you what I
have an even bigger that whether or not
she is black guys are very into her her
DMS her Nipsey Hussle
yeah she oh he got killed didn't he yeah
is that Kurt event yeah we'll save it
God hold on Ilana
my body's overloading oshi sushi is may
I see that one just that's a classy [ __ ]
though yeah
I mean that's just hey can you be a
little bit more graceful you show your
ass who was on the bed like so I should
let me see a few then she farted it
would be better if she farted so that's
not too obvious no this is classy no she
gets she get his dick stay soft if he
ain't got my fee see she's she's a pearl
she's a stone-cold killer yeah she's a
person stay soft if you don't have that
feet okay all right where's the hold up
will you pay
in other words are you paying and why do
you look at um
um for sale at least she's very uh do
she screams white guys what else get you
holy [ __ ] that is in Houston Texas -
yeah well that's that's list listen any
athletes calling all athletes in town
yeah calm all athletes all over the
world yeah I bet to get time man sure
sure it's a big girl she's very sexy
yeah yeah that's how she makes her
living god bless okay Kendu your head
how many dick says she sucked that's her
job
yeah I know right job there's some I
don't have a problem with that though is
that any different then I mean Lee she's
like I don't know if she's a stripper
she might be but if she's not there's
nothing there's no difference between
stripping in that like the gig right she
just taking advantage of with social
media you don't need to be a stripper
now to get out there like she's making
Bank do ya think about it that's a
pretty girl she's getting hundreds of
dollars potentially to show her feet if
you're this curvy kitten yeah you're
this curvy snowball kid who's very
sexual
you know its money she's getting a
question I don't know about is how does
that end with with marriage I mean it's
very short so well but short sided right
is it is that a crib it Jesus Christ so
dope and I should save her save your
money but here's the thing would you
would you say not that many views but
here's the thing would definitely like
alligators good luck eating her
alligator but here's the can't get his
mouth around those but here's the thing
though so what she's doing very
short-sighted
fresh athlete very short-sighted that's
why they're drawn to each other ya know
the UFC fighter it's like how's this end
you better save your money right we had
a fell player how's this ten better save
your money yeah stripper houses and
better save your money yeah it holds the
job so like you
what you do yeah how's this end yeah
it's been great for you but I'm sure
when you started people said the same
picture well you have a stand up is a
skill set that you can keep doing
forever I'm saying adding oh I can't
stand up different yeah you stay up -
it's true man acting yeah I know there
are so many people you forget how we're
working so many but he's talking with
you like let's say this series goes
great right and then it gets picked up
another season then maybe just falls off
a be designed to it you're back with
your back in the pool correct you're
back in the rack trying to get picked up
it that's correct
that's why I going on out yes yes you
can stand up I know that says you didn't
have this oh you're I mean I know guy I
know too many people that live it every
day you're welcome dude thank you thank
you I know so many people that that deal
with that but I know people who judge
this [ __ ] out like listen do I want her
to be the mother to my child [ __ ] no
what I take her for the Houston reside
yeah yeah pay cold hard
well earned stand-up cat I have known
artists she's used to the improv no
judgment on it I don't have any
celebrate it's just old they all you
know what they say the oldest profession
in the world is its classes you know
what the oldest profession in the world
is Rob you know for that's right
prostitution is they think it's
considered the oldest profession in the
world that you know that's the same know
what though who judges this just other
women and no dudes like I can't
of course not shut the [ __ ] and and and
it's always been contentious because
other women judge it because naturally
they go that girl is that she's taken my
manly my man is moonlighting on me with
that right and I get it yeah but also
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] block yeah you
know though remember this to a lot of
those women a lot of those women end up
when the ride ends a lot of them get
married to a dude she's hot and they
make great moms and they make great wife
when the music stops it doesn't mean
that they're all safe I get on this
plane may not be the smartest person I
don't know don't hold up
I've on this planet for 36 years yeah
I've had my run-in with strippers some
of them are the best people I know some
more dope also some of them are so
business savvy yes if I am funniest few
alumni for your strippers car
think she's business savvy yeah
blac Chyna mm-hmm
yeah this some of it is it's it is a
what's the word it is a type of person
typically I was talking to chameleon I
would give away so I'm Sam we're and I
go dude you have a girlfriend and he
goes no not really I'm kind of seeing
this girl we just sleep together and IOD
it and I knew the answer he's gonna
listen to you what the [ __ ]
and I went do you get a lot of girls and
clearly does it he goes I use just hired
professionals just dead I just I prefer
I like that I appreciate that me too
congratulations and a lot less problems
look I got no problem with any of that
none and by the way it is true that
there are plenty of strippers and plenty
of hookers quote unquote that end up
retiring and make gray wives and and
some strippers awesome people now some
of them [ __ ] mercenaries mercenaries
yes so same with dudes but again some
fighters great do you okay some of them
if you're still up I knew a girl I knew
a girl who was a straight up working
girl okay in that this pasta - yes and
she said to me I interviewed her for a
[ __ ] TV show vodka no and I said to
her I said what is it that guy she goes
well I remember I was so poor my mother
worked in a in a slaughterhouse and then
she worked as a waitress in this in this
podunk diner was the only diner around
we were and they lived in Howard
Johnson's and in motels and she would
take the coins she made from tips and
they would put him out on the bed and
they could they would divvy out to see
what kind of food they could get and
whether or not they could eat chicken or
meat that when you grew up that [ __ ]
poor yeah you will never be broke again
oh and then you're really pretty and
you're and men are looking at you and
they'll give you so you've never seen
more than you've never seen more than a
thought you never see more than five
hundred dollars in your life in one
place and the guy goes I'll give you 500
bucks to suck my dick whitey
whatever it might be something listen
you're making for some rumors she's
making millions of dollars maybe so
these girls charge what three grand an
evening or whatever
four grand I don't know no worth it cute
doggies when you see my back rip I pull
myself up like a champ like a chimp
through thirty times bad while talking
to you why wouldn't I give that to you
as it's a gif it's a gift it's a gift